hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans l'appli
messenger et utam le styliste dû cliquer
sur démarrer pour que notre aventure
commence je t'attends rejoint vite sur
messenger
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on joue pour un kilo de bonbons comment
s'appelait paris à l'époque des gaulois
comment s'appelait paris à l'époque des
gaulois c'est juste mais dit ça
attention vous allez me paie 10 à lutter
c'est pas j'imagine mais où sa mitaine
luttait non moi je mange sur le thème au
loyer mais licha c'est bon c'est gagné
bravo mise à la une au bois soit
question le sinistre en route parce que
nous si on répond mal on sait qu'on est
des remarques mais mélissa theuriau
alors elle m'a répondu à la question de
ces éléments on était très mal ou pas du
tout pas et tous les tweets 10
la preuve vivante qu'on peut être belle
talentueuse intelligente c'est une
journaliste sympathique très
professionnel et faire des reportages
pour ouvrir les débats excellente
journaliste un blessé docs sont parfaits
bref j'adore je vous dise a marqué là
que du positif et je vais vous faire un
aveu ai je dit aux téléspectateurs
pensée moyens je vais aller on n'a pas
eu de tweets
c'est que voilà et je suis la personne
qui tu aimes le plus sur ce plateau km à
la défaut comme c'est quoi rime à rien
elle est heureuse en amour
bah ouais mais ça nous fait plaisir ça
fait un ami tant que c'est qu'un ami
chabat et c'était avec un ennemi on
l'aurait foutu dehors leur jeter des
pierres aux prévenus
ah bah non c'est vrai il avait regardé
regardes et tu veux faire quoi en
politique mais j'aimerais bien un jour
moins dix journalistes d'accord comme
quand même comme midi c'est à toi voilà
journaliste politique doit s'aimer mais
ça c'est un petit modèle est génial